I've got an experiment for you first
take a limb any of your limbs second cut
it off
third profit actually our lawyers would
probably appreciate it if I said that
that is in fact not a good idea at all
it's just a thought experiment to get
you thinking about the axolotl an
incredible salamander that can regrow
entire lost limbs so what's so special
about the axolotl well as it turns out
nothing really we have the same genes
that salamander has because long long
ago we shared a common ancestor that
have our problem is we don't use these
genes the same way the axle out of it
so we scar you see healing is a
complicated process certain steps have
happened in the right order in order to
scar or regenerate when our wounds heal
it actually begins with a little bit of
regeneration but early on we take a
different path in scar instead the axle
all is the opposite it begins with a
little bit of scarring but it's genes
work in such a way that eventually leads
to full-tilt regeneration if you're
thinking hey if we have the same genes
why don't we hack our bodies to
regenerate instead of scar well
scientists are way ahead of biologists
David Gardner of the University of
california-irvine for instance was an
axolotl lab and things we absolutely one
day will unlock the salamander secrets
and apply them to ourselves it wasn't
that long ago 20 years ago people would
say well do you really think this is
gonna happen and here we are 20 years
later the most common question I get
asked is when is it going to happen it's
like almost everybody has already
accepted the regeneration will happen
someday why not now what's taking so
long what could you to make it happen
sooner that's a complete mind shift it
gets weirder still what if science can
figure out how to not only grow back
limb but to grow it back better what if
I get those muscles I've always wanted